hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to discuss the magic numbers
495 and 6174 which are known as the
cupricker constants
although these numbers are quite
ordinary i'm going to show you how all
three digit numbers are related to 495
and how all four digit numbers are
related to 6174
we'll start out with three digit numbers
let's take a number like 927
we're going to go through a series of
steps to show you how this number is
related to 495
the first step in the procedure is we're
going to rearrange the digits of 927 to
make the largest number we can
and if we do that the largest number we
can make is nine seven two
on the flip side we're going to
rearrange the digits to make the
smallest number we can
and when we rearrange these digits the
smallest number we can make is 279
and what we're going to do is we're
going to subtract the smaller number
from the larger number
and we end up with 693
from our result 693 we're going to
repeat the process
so we'll make the largest number we can
963
and we'll make the smallest number we
can from those same digits
subtracting the two numbers
we get 594
once again we'll repeat the process
to make the largest and smallest numbers
and subtract them
and we've ended up with the result 495
and once you get to the result 495
when you rearrange the digits to make
the largest and smallest numbers
you keep staying at 495.
so we've taken a number 927
and we've ended up with the the number
495
and once we're at this number 495 we
keep staying at that number
the interesting part is this is going to
work for any almost any three digit
number
we'll do another example
123.
we rearrange the digits to make the
largest and smallest numbers
and we subtract the two numbers
and we're going to repeat the process
and we keep repeating the process
and once again we are going to end up at
the number 495
so this process of rearranging the
digits to be the largest number possible
and the smallest number possible
subtracting the two and repeating
gets us to 4.95
this will even work with numbers that
include a zero
so 420
the smallest number we can make is 024
and our result is 396
and when we repeat this process
we once again end up at 4.95
and so that's what's special about the
number 495.
whenever you start with a three digit
number
as long as the three digits are not all
the same
you go through the steps of arranging
the digits to make the largest and
smallest numbers
you take the smaller number from the
larger number and you keep repeating
this over and over
and eventually you will always get 4.95
and it's quite amazing because 495
doesn't strike you
as a number that you've heard before in
math class but this will always happen
you'll always end up with the same
number of 495.
quite interestingly
there's a similar number for four digit
numbers
so let's start out with two three four
five
if we make the largest number possible
and the smallest number possible
we subtract the smaller from the larger
and we keep repeating this process
eventually we're going to get to 6174
and once we're at that number
we'll keep staying at that number over
and over again
so 6174 is the four-digit magical number
and it works exactly the same way you
start out with any four-digit number you
make the largest and smallest numbers
you subtract the smaller from the larger
and you keep repeating and you will
always end up at six one seven four
so it's a pretty neat trick you can try
it out with any examples you want you
will eventually get to
for the three digit numbers 495 and the
four digit numbers 6174
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory
you can also catch me at my blog
mindyourdecisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker